[Music]
I think to stand for the Merrill tea
you've got to be a little bit
self-confident you actually got to know
you want to do the job and can do the
job and I guess I felt that I could I
worked with for years and I had a huge
amount of knowledge of council processes
and so on and I thought it was a job
that I can do
I became mayor one month after the
September 2010 earthquake and dealing
with all the issues and the changes of
government policy and a community that
was very distressed a lot of people
across the district having difficulty
but particularly in cowboy and in Pine
Skye rocky there was a whole lot of
community groups that were disrupted and
you know in the staff and other agencies
government agencies NGOs and so under
they a fantastic job and getting our
community up and running again and that
happened very quickly so I never felt
overwhelmed I felt that with all that
all those people wishing together we
would get
I think is coming through the
earthquakes and developing to town
centers and carpel and run euro which I
I think are pretty good and Sydney a lot
of people so they are one other small
thing we've entered the local government
excellence program and about a third of
councils in New Zealand have gone
through that and we have reached the top
grade that only one other council has
actually achieved nothing that says a
lot for governance staff and the way our
community works with their council
I'll describe a particularly bizarre day
because later on the government set up a
committee to look at what's what the
raven were going to be made after sarah
stopped operation we were deciding the
future of this part of Canterbury so
that was the morning in the afternoon
there was a runaway rooster and blackhat
street brand-new hora and the people
there didn't really not to do is that do
you think the staff are taking totally
seriously and and I thought my afternoon
occupied by the risk
in particular I'll miss being with other
councils other mayors those kinds of
meetings which I enjoy the Canterbury
mural forum has been particularly asked
six years has been particularly
effective and the other thing I'll
missus action staff because when you
Amir you you've got your own office you
got in the building in and out of the
building all the time it's a full-time
job and although I don't have far away
from the building I won't be in it and
I'll certainly must said it's like
anybody leaving a job really well I
think that they're fairly clear it's the
same fun as for local government across
New Zealand it's fresh water quality its
climate change the impact on of dealing
with those on our local economy there's
really big issues around stormwater in
urban areas and of course there are
particular immediate issues that are
likely arise around drinking water cause
[Music]
more time to do things they haven't got
time to do now our grandchildren live in
Australia I hope we can get across there
more often it's been longer when I'm
there I think I don't get bored easily
so I'll have no trouble filling my days
and I don't feel that I couldn't do the
mural drive anymore I Marilyn I Oh same
age and we just think it's time
[Music]